there is no excuse for not trying where
you are right now doesn't have to
determine where you'll end up no one's
written your destiny for you
most people push themselves a little bit
but they're nowhere close to doing their
best I never let anybody else control my
destiny my mom's taught me to make
things happen on my own not to depend on
anybody rise and shine it's expresso
time what's up believe nation it's up in
my one word is believe and I believe in
you I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
on to the world so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message write your own
destiny over to you Barack Obama maybe
someone in your family has lost their
job and there's not enough money to go
around maybe you live in a neighborhood
where you don't feel safe or have
friends who are pressuring you to do
things you know aren't right there is no
excuse for not trying where you are
right now it doesn't have to determine
where you'll end up no one's written
your destiny for you because here in
America you write your own destiny you
make your own future one of the most
important habits you can develop for
yourself is to learn to try your best
every single day and this applies to
being an entrepreneur it applies to
being a husband or wife it applies to
every areas of your life it applies to
the goals that you are setting for
yourself
here's a great practice at night you
look at your goals and then you say did
I try my best to accomplish that goal
that I try my best to be a great
entrepreneur did I try my best to be a
great husband or a great father a great
mother a great wife did I try my best
most people don't most people Coast most
people come nowhere close to trying
their best most people do just enough to
get by most people push themselves a
little bit but they're nowhere
close to doing their best and you have
no excuse and no reason not to try your
best on the regular basis and it's a
great check-in on a daily basis because
people will let you off the hook your
friends your family your spouse a lot of
times they'll let you off the hook the
sable look you're working so hard look
at all the effort that you put in in but
you know you know you know you know you
could have done better you know you
could have pushed a little bit harder
you know that wasn't your best and I
want you to start to feel like if
yesterday wasn't your best if you didn't
give your all to yesterday to make it
great that you're gonna do it today
because we're coasting because you think
you have so much time but you don't
you're window of opportunity is closing
this idea that you have to build
something amazing will not be available
in a couple years it won't be available
forever you have one life make it count
and you make it count by doing your best
every single day and again this applies
to not just business it's not just that
you have to work 24 hours a day and
that's your best
what does best look like for you and how
often are you hitting it defining that
for yourself and then judging yourself
against your own criteria because in my
life people will let me off the hook all
the time they think I'm doing so many
amazing things I am my harshest critic I
am the one pushing myself as far as I
can go to say I know I can do better I
know this video can be better I know
tomorrow's weather can be even better
than what I recorded today I know I have
the ability and so therefore I must go
out and create something better so I
would strongly encourage you to every
night have a check-in and ask yourself
did I do my best to accomplish my goals
today and move them forward and if not
then commit to doing a better job
tomorrow now I want else I add that
sometimes your best isn't good enough
yet and yet is the key word sometimes
your best you gave your best it was
amazing for what you could do but it
still was good enough you tried to make
a youtube video and you gave your best
at it and the video sucked and nobody
watched it and you got no comments you
tried your best to learn the piano or
create a piece of art or whatever the
thing was you tried your best at
and you've got zero results expect that
to happen sometimes your best is not
good enough yet with practice with
repetition with drilling with doing it
over and over and over again you will
get better and it will become more than
good enough to expect to be great at
something at the beginning is a fool's
errand and I think this is what holds a
lot of entrepreneurs back they go crazy
for three months they put everything
they've got into making this business
happen and it doesn't lift and they say
that's it my best wasn't good enough and
then they quit and then you live the
rest of your life when your gret saying
I just wish I gave a little bit more or
somebody else made tons of money off of
my idea what I encourage you to think
about I guarantee you I guarantee you I
guarantee you if you gave your best on a
consistent basis if day in and day out
you gave your best in the effort you
were putting out in the education coming
in in trying to develop and improve your
skills and understanding of the thing
that you're trying to get better about
if you felt like you gave your best
every day I guarantee you things will
get better it may not be today it may
not be tomorrow it may not be in a week
it may not be in a month but I guarantee
you if you give your best if you don't
quit if you don't give up if you give
your best every single day things will
get better and you will surprise
yourself at what you're able to create
now I've got some really special bonus
cups for you but before that question of
the day I want to know what are you
working on
to be the best stack what are you
working on that you can improve that you
can ask yourself tonight was I the best
at this today what is that thing leaving
the comments below really curious to
find out thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clips
more espresso give me go
was there some pivotal moment for you in
your life where you just really got it
and and something happened a fire
ignited inside you that made it so that
you had all the moving parts to make
this amazing career unfold I think the
death of my mother probably got me
really focused and I understood that
there wasn't gonna be anyone there to
take care of me had to take care of
myself and just out of respect for her
life and all the things she did to make
me a better person I had to apply all
those things so you know at like 17 my
mother died when I was 16 or 17 you know
I was running the streets so heavy and
it was getting so critical then I put
myself in boarding school you know I
figured out how to get a scholarship and
because of the ability that my mother
gave me to articulate what's on my mind
to read to write you know cannot be
afraid and also I was you know boxing so
I got went to the boys club and they
were given our scholarship for you know
he took a test I passed the test and you
know I made it and I was just always
able to put myself in a better place I
never let anybody else control my
destiny my mom's taught me to make
things happen on my own not to depend on
anybody and if I have an opinion to
speak on it life demands that you pick
up the pace if you don't pick up the
pace you're gonna be left behind I'm
amazed at the people that lack the
flexibility to pick up the pace they
just get in a red I scroll down here and
I'm gonna scroll back I'm gonna stroll
over here I'm gonna stroll over there
one of the most amazing thing about the
disaster at Malaysia is that when it
happened everybody had to pick up the
pace all the news media had to pick up
the pace
they were booking night flights and
flying over here and flying over there
somebody had to work overtime won't be
home for three days typing in the middle
of night research going or because when
something happens everybody gotta pick
up the pace that's why I can't deal with
people who cannot pick up the pace don't
be strolling when I
man one one on you Andy people who can
pick up the pace slap your name and say
pick up the pace something's about to
happen pick up the pace something's
about to happen pick up the pace
something's about to happen pick up the
pace something's about to happen pick up
the pace something is about to happen
pick up the pace something's about to
have it I came to tell the young people
pick up the pace pick up pick up
the danger of low expectations
I would rather aim for the stars and not
hit them then to not aim at all I would
rather go after it and not get it did
not go after it at all I'd rather try
and fail did not try at all I don't want
to live with the idea wonder what would
have happened had I done more with my
life
I'm gonna go for it come hell or high
water I'm going after my destiny concern
able say run you gotta run after your
destiny you can't stroll after your
destiny
you can't walk after your destiny you
gotta run
somebody ha
you've gotta run you gotta run you gotta
run
you can't just wake up in the morning
let me see what's gonna happen today I
don't know I just woke up oh you should
stay in the bed give the day to somebody
who's gone wrong after that that's today
give the day to somebody who has a plan
who has a strategy because success is
never an accident and if you don't want
to do something with their life my
message and something of me moving
forward is how powerful we are all are
as individuals and how you know you know
looking into more reasons as to how I
got to where I am today and even
something simple like I was doing an
interview earlier and they asked about
visualization I'm like I've actually
done visualization since I was in
go-karting like pictured the perfect lap
and so you know trying to figure out
what it is that's got me to this point
and then how to go deeper yeah but you
know we are powerful individuals in and
of ourselves and create our own destiny
and so that's an important message raise
your standard not one drop of most self
worth depends on your acceptance of me I
don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details